كابتن حاتم المغرب ايضا على مشارف انجاز
تاريخي
اعتقد ان الرجراجي يمشي في الطريق الصحيح
ووصل الى المعادله السريع الصحيحه المراه
تصدرت المجموعه
في المجموعه حقيقه ب 7 نقاط كذلك
لانه يتكلموا على مدرب محلي
هذا النجاح منذ 86 المغرب لم ينل شرف
التاهل الى الدوري الدوري الدور الثاني
اليومياتي وليد الركراكي في في اشهر يعني
قليله يقوم بالتغيير وكذلك لا ننسى انه
كان له اعاد زياش ومزراوي وكذلك حمد الله
ثلاث لاعبين كان مغضوب عليهم
لانه هذا المدرب لا نتكلم فقط على الامور
الفنيه والتكتيكيه نتكلم كذلك على الجانب
الذهني والجانب النفسي يعني من افضل
المدربين وحكيم يتكلم على هذا الشاكر في
في المؤتمر صحفي ولذلك هذا المدرب يحسب له
ما وصل اليه المغرب لحد الان ونتمنى ان
شاء الله المغرب
في مباراه القادمه من اسبانيا اسبانيا
اكيد فيها قويه واسبانيا لديها امكانيات
كبيره لكن لدينا ثقه في هذا الجيل ال همم
الجيل المواهب الذي تسخر به المغرب وكذلك
وليد الرجراجي المدرب الشاب اللي لديه
الامكانيات وانا اقول هذا المدرب مدرب
تكتيكي بانتهال فاتمنى المغرب ان تحقق
المشهود وهو المرور الى الدول الى
الثمانيه ان شاء الله واحنا املنا حقيقه
كبير في المغرب واحنا اكيد ورا المغرب ورا
ان شاء الله الجماهير المغربيه وان شاء
الله في الغد نفرح لتاهل ان شاء الله في
المنتخب المغربي
كان يقدم مستوى ويفوز ونقول المنتخبنا انا
في وجهه نظري لاول مره يتحد العرب في كاس
العالم في مونديال قطر
السعوديه قطر
اللي يتكلم فيها الكابتن احنا نتكلم فيها
على المنتخب المغربي
على مدرب مستلم المنتخب قبل شارعنا قدر
انه يجمع الفريق يقدر انه يعمل في الفريق
في لاعبين عندهم مشاكل كثيره سابقه مع
المدربين جوي صاروا وهم الابرز في الفريق
تكلم على زياش تتكلم على عبد الله على
مزراوي هذه التوليفه اللي موجوده في
المنتخب المغربي ما موجود عند اي منتخب
عربي لصراحه للامانه اذا كانت على الصعيد
المهاري الفردي الخططي واشكلنا بعض
الاحيان في مباراه الاولى مع كرواتيا كم
تحفظ بشكل كبير في المباراه بعدها تحرر في
المباراه الثانيه وتحرر معه مباراه
انا يوم يوم غدا ان شاء الله اتمنى ان
المنتخب المغربي اني يكون متوازن متى ما
كان متوازن مع فريق بحجم اسبانيا رح تخطف
في المباراه متى شويه دفعت زياده وتحمست
زياده احيانا احنا حضور الجماهيري
والتواجد الجماهيري ونلعب بقلبي
بعقل عكس المنتخبات الكبيره التي تلعب
دائما باستراتيجيه وخطه عمل واضحه لكنه
الثقه اللي احنا جالسين نتكلم فيها ما
اجتني مش وليده اللحظه لا في مستوى كبير
قدام المنتخب المغربي كابتن حاتم
تفضل في ميزه للمغرب لانه نتكلم في
اسبانيا حكيمي يلعب في في ريال مدريد كلمه
كذلك لاعبين كبار
لاعبين في في الدوري الايطالي لاعبين في
الدوري الفرنسي همم كذلك احتياط ممتازه
تسخر بمواهب فنيه كبيره ولذلك اكيد نحن
نخاف على المغرب انه لا تدخل لكننا نعتقدا
وهذا المدرب حتى ولو انه بنتكلم عن المدرب
انا في 2014
[موسيقى]
في التدريب صغير السن مع مهارات معقول
يعني صغير السن لكن تفكيره كبير مع طينه
المدربين الكبار فقط
يعلم جيدا انه قادر ان يذهب بهذا المنتخب
بعيدا وهو صرح بذلك وقال نحن قادري قادرون
انه ينافس وانا جايه تعجبني هذه ال همم
لماذا نحن لا نحن بفريق يكون قادر الذها
بعيده لما لا المنافسه علقب نعم البرازيل
القوي والارجنتين قوي وفرنسا قويه
وانجلترا قوي لكن كذلك لدينا لاعبون
لاعبين يلعبوا فيه في افضل فرق الاوروبيه
ولما المغرب لا خبره لا لا لا
في بهذا الحلم حتى اذا لم ينال مراد
بالنسبه للمغرب فيك في شرف المحاوله عن
لماذا نحن الفرق العربيه الافريقيه
والاسيويه ال- ال- نشارك نشاركه جيده
ويكفينا لا المغرب لديها جيل قادر ان
تذهبي بعيده